concern is growing over the safety of
air travel as the first domestic Ebola
patient fights the disease it turns out
the man's journey back to the u.s. from
Liberia stand for airports on three
continents but the CDC says he wasn't
contagious while traveling because he
hadn't shown any symptoms yet Shelby
Holliday has been looking into this so
first of all it would be worrying had
you been on the same flight with this
guy but the CDC says don't worry yeah
the good news is that Ebola is not
airborne as we've heard many times it's
only transmitted via bodily fluids but
given this news I was starting to reach
out to see how airlines are prepared to
handle more infected passengers if
they're prepared to handle infected
planes and the responses I got were
pretty alarming the Federal Aviation
Administration says the FE the FAA does
not have rules on decontaminating planes
and airline would consult the CDC on
that CDC told me i would suggest
speaking with an airline and when I talk
to Airlines they say they're complying
with CDC guidelines so it appears that
there are no official rules no official
oversight when it comes to
decontaminating plans and sanitizing
airplanes for passengers the CDC does
have guidelines and it does tell
airplane airlines to follow these
certain rules they recommend using
protective gear washing hands treating
bodily fluids as infectious those are
kind of no brainers here and the
airlines are telling me that they do
have procedures in place and safety is a
priority but again there there's no
official oversight it appears there are
no rules have had the airlines on which
this man flew contacted all of the other
passengers to just make them aware that
they were on that flight that is unclear
at this point we do know it was a united
plane coming from Brussels to Washington
DC and then Washington Washington DC to
Dallas we have not spoken to passengers
yet the the CDC was trying to focus on
the symptoms in Dallas and the people he
was in contact with in Dallas but the
pad there is reason for passengers to be
worried however I spoke to analysts and
they say that at this point if the news
gets worse things could get worse for
airlines but at this point the impact
will be smallish because there because
Ebola is not airborne like h1n one or
sorry
it doesn't pose as big of a risk to the
airlines and again this man is in dallas
now that's where he was infected he was
not infected on the actual airplane
right well i'm sure people on those
planes anyway we'll be taking their
temperature